hey it's so wonderful to see you again
yes
i i must confess that until earlier
today i didn't realize how historic your
performance tonight
was going to be i didn't need to be
honest i'm still i can't believe that
when someone said it to me i'm like what
wow so talk a little bit
or a lot about that and what it means to
you
and then what it means for us as a
community
well that whole phrase you see it you
can be it
really rings true and the only reason
why
i felt that i could pursue country music
was because i saw another black woman
singing country music named reecy palmer
and if it wasn't for her i wouldn't be
here so so me standing on that stage
representing just women of color period
it shows them that they have the
opportunity to and that they can sing
whatever kind of music they want to sing
it doesn't just have to be just r b if
they want to sing country music
they can and they will be accepted by
this beautiful community
so you were introduced by tim mcgraw and
then accompanied by keith urban you know
it doesn't get much bigger than that
talk about what it means to you to be
embraced by the country community
tonight
you know i've been pursuing music for a
very long time
and just to feel embraced by the country
music community i've always
known that they've been so loving and to
experience
it for the first time like that like it
has just been
overwhelming i'm pregnant and hormonal
so i've been trying not to cry this
whole time
but it is just it really does mean so
much to me
to be embraced by this community i know
we've been talking so much all year long
about diversity in country music and a
lack of representation
and i know you've always said that you
just really sing your truth so
what was going through your mind tonight
while you were singing your truth on
stage well first of all i have
three amazing canadian songwriters that
wrote this song with me
victoria banks emily karen kasowski who
wrote and also produced it
and that first of all means so much to
me and
and just just stand here and sing such a
polarizing song
on the acm awards about protecting our
future
protecting our daughters protecting
women because we're so
important and we matter and it's just
been such an honor to be able to stand
here
and and and be that to people i just
wanted to ask you
obviously for so many reasons 2020 has
been
such a monumental year and one thing
that i am hopeful about and that i
am excited i don't know if that's the
right word is that
it seems like we're finally going beyond
just talking about change needs to
happen
so do you feel that do you feel like
this is an actual shift and
just share your thoughts on the fact
that it seems like we may actually be
turning at least a little bit of a point
absolutely
i am a witness to it i have seen it i'm
a part of the acm diversity task force
and the acms are relentlessly committed
to diversifying the ac awards there's a
black writer
on the show and they've really taken a
lot of our recommendations on how to
make this world so inclusive because it
actually is
all people have to do is see themselves
and feel encouraged to be a part of this
community
and they can and the acms really has
shown that tonight
and i'm just like you i feel really
really hopeful like it has just been
as hard of a year as it's been as crazy
as the year it's been
it really has been beautiful to see
people come together and put all of our
differences aside and make the world
better